[Música]
[Aplausos]
olá eu sou joana isso filha e uma
consciência das minhas filhas e minha
[Música]
[Aplausos]
escola minha mãe eu fui a uma agência
convencional não fique na polêmica
acho que aquilo que eu conhecia ela
mesmo evento muito feliz trabalhei
marido nem fim de prevenir a dengue
sinto me ensinando ao mundo mas não
gostou da chegada do grupo pequeno
receber talvez só fazem barulho e eu que
só avançava assisto que a lesão possa
abater não lembro com futura negociação
mais ligado porque foi lá que eu comprei
meu primeiro coisa gigante com legal não
foram ontem trabalharem também é a marca
do primeiro evento
você pensa que eu peguei várias coisas
o design é muito mais do que uma coisa
não é fácil
belluschi consegue sempre se consegue
[Música]
o agito é que eu de outra geração do
natal das crianças aqui um pouquinho sim
porque aqui cerveja na audiência passou
a linha surgiu e foi assim ontem o
convidou para essa história surgiu o
projeto em 2010 antes mesmo de cinco
anos depois fresco em portugal
falei para os jogos futuros a verdade é
que enfrentá lo até às oito da noite
pessoas que têm muita coisa por fazer
[Música]
melhor no ano que é um nojo de si num
inglês e joão gil e uma loja
não tenho memória emoção daquela fruta é
e eu penso longe sons qualquer certeza
que nós fizemos com salto fazer muitas
perguntas função disso nós e vai às
aulas mesmo local do mesmo mês
quem vamos entender também como pessoas
como a senhora com mais atenção em
momentos em que assim eu quem comprou
mais quente
[Música]
essas e outras 250 pessoas deixariam os
costumes dessas profundas
amanhã 11 com os 100 escritórios certa
antes e também muitas coisas por fazer
com que os fãs apaixonados opção é e não
só conquistou ontem no fim e não vai
jogar não será pois estávamos a chegar
num lugar das mãos dos jovens
na missiva então é isso nos quais a
linguagem os filhos e como sabe o que
também é conselheiro do time isso nos
ensina genta amanhã ia pra nós temos a
maioria das pessoas dando aquele seu
corpo exposta diretamente pra frente foi
só ele passa um tempo falou em alguém
que é o nosso chefe esse problema fusão
é bom que ela foi responsável sozinha em
casa e fazer cursos serão os alimentos
com os fãs apaixonados
quando eu contei isso não é problema
a família pagou uma conexão que eu tenho
e frank não costumo sair 2009 mostrou
uma série de opções e não forma cuidada
que a garra e não falar com ela
diferente do esperado pela mãe e pela
minha mãe que toda a gente quer as
mesmas gnr
não faz hoje um ferido da linha é a
nossa vez mais trabalhadores tinham
costa forma com essa forma trazendo seu
plano agência das mães no colo trabalhar
e olhar outras coisas incerteza para
fazer as coisas certas muito menos comum
saber do grande que a lei manda vez
menezes é e os meias encontradas em
sites que são nosso primeiro disco é um
serviço prestado pela companhia dizer
que há cinco anos tinha em 10 anos com
um não despertar esta manhã em nyon que
não está ainda nos cuidados é quem é uma
coisa não consegue ir lá fora que é uma
baixaria quero mais
rafael foi essa atenção das fãs tanto o
espírito é estranho estar aí escala que
qualquer coisa é que nós fizemos
combinado sem concessões
joão no porto ban ki-moon família e até
alguma coisa nele uma porta cédula vai
fazendo com que eles farão sucesso
design enquanto anselmo audiências
coisas então mostrei para 10 uma
importância da banda chamado nós também
perdemos mãe de deus em diagonal
assim o chamam a atenção da gente à
espera das pessoas em ter essa coisa que
nem ela nem como costa anda louco
nela e cerveja
com isso durante o verão no sul a contar
nunca saiu da cidade diz a minha
agora quero ser um big fone e algumas
políticos diz que fusão parcial da
empresa
no entanto que a oposição unida não
podemos comentar
eu juro que eu sou vamos lançar seu
piano filme que você quer fizemos aqui
éo serviço porque a área não é uma festa
mesmo empresa são as mães populaã ã o
das empresas estamos a fazer aqui o que
eu faço é ver o banco vendeu na
caminhada nas receitas em um leilão sem
celular e uma bateria cabeça escreve a
lusa
então sempre que minha mas aí eu
conclamo criada em 2004 a nossa
abstenção existe essa visão a mãe que
então
é bom que ele não vai destinar o mesmo
também a minha e fazemos isso
hoje as pessoas me inspiram
é esse nosso eu estou a brincar ou
roupas da minha boca que eu vou deixar
ele ir votando coisas a primeira é um
pouquinho eu posso ajudar a família na
escola
nessa novela foi assim que o momento é
quem vai fazer assim acho que é mais
bacana do milan é fácil mesmo muitas
vezes ficam mais uma vez mesmo que eu
cheguei pra mim isso tudo me pegar no pé
dele o meu sofrimento - ueg
[Aplausos]
[Música]